okay so um at the start of the web we we
had you know we just had tags you would
build your pages out of all of these
tags and some tags look differently to
others and there was no real reason for
that and since then we've had this
process of of trying to explain the
magic behind how pages are built up and
and then give that magic back to
developers you know so you can use that
magic to build different things so
example of that is the Dom explained the
the structure of pages a CSS explained
why like one heading was a different
side to another and you could use that
to style things differently but until
recently we couldn't really explain why
an input element look the way it did and
behave the way it did and why like a
select element was completely different
had a different set of behaviors well we
have a new explanation for that we've
got web components and in the
explanation for how all that works and
what you can do with it in how polymer
works that is going to pour forth from
the face hole of our next speaker it is
Eric bidelman big round of applause so
I'm from the u.s. I'm going to continue
the trend whoo that's it's from my
facehole so a little bit about myself my
name is Eric bidelman I work on polymer
I work on the chrome team on the
developer relations team here at Google
you can follow me on Google+ you can
follow me on Twitter there's way too
much stuff to talk about in 30 minutes
with polymer and web components so feel
free to stop by office hours chat at me
on these different channels so for those
of a herd of polymer you probably come
into the project you've seen our website
all right there's this really nice
little explanation of what the heck
polymer is and it says polymer is a new
type of library for the web it's built
on top of web components and it's
designed to leverage the evolving web
platform on modern browsers and so
that's cool it's very inspirational it's
a good little you know intro to the
project if you actually look closer
right you're going to see this little
diagram all over the place we we
overload the cinnamon places to describe
the different pieces of polymer it's a
nice Lego block building of of colors
and stuff and so when people start to
investigate polymer they say well is it
polyfills and yeah it's Polly philos is
it a framework it's it's a framework
is it UI widgets for the web yeah it's
it's that too we're working on that it's
also a set of monomers right they
combined together to form a molecule for
your science geek like me and go on
Wikipedia last night but to really
understand what polymer is you actually
have to take a step back in time to the
early days of the web in order to
understand what we're going you have to
understand where we've been so this is
what the web looks like today will
transport ourselves back in time to an
earlier day when the web look like this
or at least google com in 98 and this is
probably what your first webpage looked
like you had a couple of elements to
play with you had things like the form
tag you had selects you had dropdowns
you had list elements you know radio
buttons and so the platform is pretty
lymington what we could do but we didn't
really need anything more than that of
course since we're in the 90s we have
clippies second cousin which is
selecting and he's telling us that we're
going to build a website today oh thank
you so actually select is a really
awesome element and it's worth actually
discussing this for a few minutes with
select right you can put some options in
this thing and it just knows what to do
with those options it knows what to do
with these to learn elements and what
you get out of it is soon befall you I
don't have to touch TSS or do anything
crazy so it's really cool this works by
itself it's sort of a think of it as an
early component for the web and this is
native to the platform this is your
classic example of running out of schwag
at a conference everything is nothing's
available except for that double XL
t-shirt but the point I make here is
that we're configuring these elements
not with a bunch of script but with just
a little bit HTML just plopping an
attribute on these options and you get
you know different behavior right so
these are now great out and that XL of
course is the only one that's available
and you can move attributes to this
select element itself so i can say size
equals 4 and i can put the multiple
attribute on this element and it
completely changes the way this element
behaves now the users can select
multiple items right and we no longer
have a drop-down we have this sort of
multi select widget which is really cool
again just by changing some attributes
on this element it knows what to do with
that and you can put other stuff in this
tag it's it's smarter than you actually
think right we can put the OP grouped in
would give it a label have some options
in there and instead of you know your
common drop-down you get a completely
different UI again which is really cool
so super versatile if you think about it
and I haven't touched any code I'm just
declaring this stuff select doesn't take
everything and actually it's very picky
it knows what it wants right you can
only put options you can only put up
groups in there if you try to jam an li
in there for instance the parser is just
going to throw that out and it's not
going to render that in my drop down if
we're building components we want that
ability to to sort of selectively choose
what markup we want to deal with select
is really great by itself it has all
this ability I can configure it with
attributes now if you put it in a
different context such as a form it
takes on new responsibilities takes on
new meaning so now when it's in my form
all right somebody's going to select
this give it a couple values and that
name attribute is going to be submitted
along with the form so this is really
cool we're composing now a bigger and
bigger application based on these
smaller components of course it's got
you know a slew of properties and
methods that it has on its dom interface
and i apologize if that's very small and
you can't really see it selectedindex
for instance is a property on this Dom
interface that doesn't really make sense
as an HTML attribute if it totally makes
sense in JavaScript I wanna be able to
get at the option that's selected and
cliffy excuse me select II also fires
events right when something interesting
happens i get Dom events for this so
select it's probably way more useful
than ever thought let's flash board
today and see where we are quick gut gut
check a tab component sort of the
quintessential component for the web
these days so where are you with this
what do we have to do in order to build
a tab complying on the web when we first
started off it looks something like this
right there's a little bit of markup
we're overloading ul's we're overloading
allies and just at the bottom there we
call a little bit of script to activate
this thing and get it going and over the
years we sort of added on more and more
JavaScript less and less markup and now
we're at the point where a lot of
extremes are just jamming in gobs and
gobs of JavaScript and that's really
because the platform itself has lacked
the expressiveness that we needed to it
as we've evolved the plat more isn't
involved with us unfortunately so we're
helping and try to change that so this
is what people on end up doing right
let's pile on the JavaScript let's pile
on loads and loads JavaScript and
ultimately you know that there's
something wrong about this picture the
story is no brighter on
other side of the coin right so the
mark-up is equally as atrocious as where
we sort of moved to in the script world
this is gmail source if you open up the
dev tools at least the mark-up side I
have no idea what's going on here this
is not maintainable at all I know
they've done this on purpose but you
know as a developer right this is
actually how we build web apps it's a
night it's a nightmare it's absolutely
nightmare for the script side and the
mark-up side what what nobody nobody
likes this so we've moved really far
away from where we started from the
select the declarative nature of HTML
what the web is good at and now we're a
sad panda in the corner with a small
balloon instead of the large buttons I
don't know why I chose blooms here I
think it's just because I feel very
deflated when I think about all this
stuff but it makes me sad we can do much
much better so what if what if markup
was meaningful again if you take the
gmail chat example for instance this up
just a little bit if you take the gmail
chat example and you can imagine a world
in the case of web components where
you're declaring everything it's very
descriptive you know exactly what's
going on in this web application so i
have a hangouts module element that i've
created within that there's components
such as a hangout chat I know who it's
from it's from Paul and Eddie just by an
HTML attribute this is how you configure
this tag their profile ID inside of that
there is a discussion going out there
and inside of that there's hang out
messages each describing sort of each
individual chat message so I have a
prototype with that I can talk to Paul
Irish she's loving the web components in
Hainan and so everything is completely
self-contained because it's all a web
components all using shadow Dom I can
chat with Larry to he's not gonna say
much back to me so so that's really
awesome do I know exactly I know exactly
what's going on in this picture I don't
have to guess and that's because we can
get it back to a platform that actually
makes sense again so that's the universe
at least we conceptually feel is
relevant on the polymer team we want to
get back to that that sort of
declarative nature of the web and what
it was good at and reuse HTML and dawn
like it's first-class citizens again so
let's jump into polymer quick spoiler
alert standards are the bottom of all
this stuff so everything I'm going to
talk about today
and I won't take a deep dive into the
standards but it's all based on four wc3
specifications so we have templates
being able to define a section of Dom to
be inert and able to stamp that out for
later use that's the template tag HTML
imports so bundling up CSS JavaScript
and an HTML in a single unit and
delivering that to another application
that's great if you want to have a set
of components and deliver that to some
end-user custom elements right the bread
and butter being able to define a new
tag in HTML is super important teach the
browser sort of new tricks hangout
module hangout message etc and shadow
DOM is sort of the bedrock of all this
and you don't have to use it but you can
totally use it if you want things like
encapsulation so for the first time ever
we have the ability to encapsulate
markup capsulate DOM and encapsulate
styles so styles from your page that's
embedding you they don't bleed in and
your Styles don't bleed out to the
outside world that's super important you
can see by this this chart here that we
have a lot of a lot of implementation
going on in chrome whether it's in
stable or behind a flag Firefox is
gung-ho about all this there's open bugs
for all these specifications opera get
some of these for free with their move
to blink and i just added safari who is
going to enable as of today the template
element so a lot of products and the
native front yeah yeah Seth likes it a
lot of progress on the native front with
all all this stuff that's super exciting
but what is polymer so I sort of alluded
to this diagram before let's jump into
it just a little bit the first is it is
a set of polyfill so we want to enable
web developers to use this stuff today
it's it's really exciting stuff it's
going to change the way we do web devel
my we want you guys to play with it and
give us feedback on all the specs so the
red part of this diagram are those
polyfills seems like pointer events and
shadow DOM and custom elements that part
is really cool because that actually
goes away over time as the browsers
implement these native API is right so
that part kind of dwindled to nothing
and the rest of polymer sort of lives on
it's faster gets better because it's
using the native stuff the sugaring
layer the yellow layer of polymer that
middle section is sort of our opinion
aid way to use all these api's and
specifications together you know you can
use shadow done by itself you can use
HTML imports by itself and all these
different specs by themselves but we
want to sort of help developers learn
how to use them
together in a really coherent way and we
also provide things like data binding
some other conveniences in this layer
ultimately we want to make your life
more productive as a web developer and
the last piece probably the most working
products at this point is the UI
components the green layer at the very
top so again everything below this uses
the core it uses the platform polyfills
and we want to give you the ability to
just drop you know component on your
page a UI component that does the right
things it's responsive by default it's
60 FPS and it's using this underlying
stack so philosophy and goals we keep it
simple on Team the first and probably
the most core fundamental aspect of this
of the project and web components is
everything is an element we think that's
awesome we think HTML should be a
first-class citizen again to the web we
think it's cool and Dom feels actually
really good to work with again I can't
unless you start to play with this stuff
it actually makes a lot of sense again
you have to write tons of tons of code
eliminate boilerplate we want to make
again make your life more productive as
a web developer and so we want to remove
even in 2013 it's hard to be a web
developer it's very tedious you have to
remember things like touch events
pointer events and all this other stuff
we want to remove all that the last
piece is to utilize the modern web
platform so if you have you know a hand
on the steering wheel you have a hand on
the gear shifter but you always have
your eyes sort of looking backwards you
can ever really progress the platform
forward and really show you know
developers and and the web what can be
done so we're only supporting the latest
version of modern browsers turns out
it's also very hard to polyfill things
like shadow Dom for for old IE so let's
talk about elements we're going to go up
and talk about that that top layer of
the stack and the mantra here if you
remember is that everything is an
element everything is an element so what
do we mean by everything is an element
well this is one example if Ajax was
just part of the browser today you would
probably use it as an element you
probably wouldn't write a lot of
JavaScript code and so that's exactly
the approach we taken with the polymer
Ajax tag the way you can figure this tag
is you give it a URL right just an HTML
attribute very akin to the Select
element you configuring this element
using attributes it's all declarative
and then you're passing in a parameters
attribute as well
with some additional parameters for that
URL and so instead of writing a bunch of
xhr code every time I start an ass you
know I'm just basically dropping this on
my page and it knows exactly what to do
with that and i'm configuring it from
the outside via parameters attributes
and I wire up a little bit of JavaScript
just like the select element fires a
change event when somebody select
something new this element is going to
fire a polymer response event and then I
can subscribe to that fetch this element
from the Dom subscribe to that and just
use the same techniques i'm used to json
parser parser response from this JSON
feed this element has also an API just
like in the cases select it has you know
API methods i can call on its dom
interface so there's this go method that
i can call and so this feels really good
because i can reuse this each every time
i need ajax in my application everything
is an element thinking about layout
using nothing but elements so i don't
know how many people have try to use CSS
flexbox but it's it's pretty painful too
great this one guy it's an awesome
awesome CSS feature right we've needed
this for a long time but it's still very
intricate and you have to know a lot of
things about it so if you remember for
the cases select right select was able
to rearrange its children give me some
default UI without much work at all on
the approach at the polymer team what
we've taken is let's make a polymer flex
layout tag and inside of it it's
children just know to be flexed children
and so now I can configure this tag with
attributes so i can change vertical i
can just remove that attribute and the
element just knows what to do with its
children and of course default back to a
row representation i can i can toggle
the Flex attribute on its children
elements and of course it'll do the
right thing so it takes a lot of the
burden out of knowing you know some of
these new technologies under the hood i
can literally just have this thing to do
what it's supposed to do which is
arranged my page in a certain way it's
kind of conceptually interesting to
think about elements that actually don't
render anything so Ajax or it's not
rendering something its utility elements
doing something on the page saying with
the layouts doing something on the page
it's not actually showing me stuff and
we've been playing around with a lot of
these none I call the non-visual utility
elements things like layout for CSS grid
and flexbox we have a media query
element that just handles you know doing
media queries in firing events for that
just drop this in and reuse this and you
don't have to worry about that stuff
anymore tags for dealing with a single
page application or shared state polymer
local storage is actually pretty cool so
you know if you tie this up to another
element you get some change events you
pass some data using data binding to it
and I'll show you example that and you
persist data to local stores you'll have
to worry about hooking that up yourself
and then other things like polymer
signals being able to broadcast messages
to different components on the page or
to the broader page so conception it's a
little bit weird to like drop this stuff
on your page and it doesn't like
rendering a UI just for instance reads a
file what a tag that reads a file it's
crazy but once you get into the polymer
core it starts to really really make
sense and on top of that we have a set
of UI elements that we're working on so
this is what people think about when
they think of components right the UI
that you plop on your page and you you
know your usual suspects apply here we
have things like a polymer UI card and
basically what you do is you drop this
on your page and you get things like
swiping functionality for free with
touch events and pointer events it's
pretty nice we have a sidebar menu item
so you just drop this markup on your
page and you get a usual sort of site
navigation with the little thing that
follows you and it's got animations it's
all 60 FPS but the really cool thing
about this is it's just a bunch of
markup right so I'm not writing any code
to actually reuse this element I'm just
declaring polymer UI side menu on my
page it's got attributes like selected
that I can figure it with labels so
we're using parts of the platform
already inside of it it knows what to do
with its children and it is expects a
certain type of children respects
polymer UI sub menu item and so that's
what's rendering all this just a bunch
of tags so it's really easy as a
developer to know what's going on here
and to maintain and to use it's
important to note that web p bunch
really lend themselves very nicely to
compose ability and reusability so we're
actually using for a lot of the UI
elements that we're creating we're using
these utility elements under the hood so
for instance polymer selector is this
sort of selecting widget that manages
state and selecting those menu items and
so we're reusing stuff we don't to
reinvent the wheel each and every time
we start a new app we can just compose
an app out of components so this is the
world we're creating we hope is really
excited
for developers this is the universe's as
I see it this is actually the video I
played the beginning is a polymer
application it's written by John
McCutcheon on the dart team he used the
polymer dart port and it's pretty cool
because I absolutely no zero about WebGL
but i do know HTML very well and so he
created a bunch of custom elements for
working with you know 3d scene and so
this is just wrapping his WebGL library
you can see I can change the earth just
by changing an attribute on this element
I can scroll up and change the texture
of the Sun and just by changing a source
attribute to a new URL WebGL is is
updating that texture will make it the
yep web components are the center of our
solar system so that's really cool
because I don't again I don't know
anything about WebGL but I know a ton
about HTML and I can read exactly what's
going on each one of these tags knows
what to do with its children render that
scene in a certain way so let's talk
about how you actually build a polymer
element or web component this is the
yellow layer in the center this is the
sugaring layer convenience AP is the
goal here is to eliminate boilerplate we
want to make it really easy for you to
develop web components so polymer has a
number of features the moral of the
story here I'll just play through the
first couple is that we want to make
things super declarative if I haven't
made that clear right now we want things
to be declarative we think it's very
powerful to do that again so instead of
writing a bunch of code to register an
element in the browser you basically
declare a polymer element its
declarative form to extend an element
use the extends attribute on your
element to extend another component we
have things like data binding right your
typical double mustache context if I
want a day to bind this inputs value
I'll just set up a property and data
bind it we have a declarative event so
once this on dash event name in this
case I click happens when it's fired
this is going to this property on your
method on your element is going to be
called and then we have a bunch of other
stuff things like property observation
reacting to state when this property
changes do this give me this callback
the last one pointer events and pointer
show is pretty cool right this is a
really evolving awesome specification
that sort of unifies input on the web
and you get this for free if you're
building a polymer element you don't
have to worry about touch
it's just built into the model goal here
again is to be declarative and write
less code and what I mean by write less
code is actually now we're in the
platform they are the sort of the core
or the polyfill layer so if you wanted
to just use the specifications by
themselves to create an element you
would actually write this each and every
time this is the template tag see if I
can zoom in just a tad so I have my
markup using a template tag the inert
section of markup that I'm going to
stamp out for each instance of the
element that's created then what I do is
I write a little script I read a
prototype God knows writing prototypes
are crazy I have a created call back
this is all part of the custom elements
API creating shadow Dom out of the
template that I'm just creating and then
I call document register so there's a
lot of stuff going on just to register a
simple simple tag that does nothing
other than render some an input so it's
pretty crazy we think we can do better
and so that's where polymer element
comes in what's cool about polymer
element is that we've created a custom
element that allows you to create custom
elements which is crazy but it's using
again the document register under the
hood so you declare your polymer element
you give it the name of the tag you're
going to create maybe give a constructor
people want to call you using the new
operator in JavaScript and then inside
of the polymer element you just drop
your markup using the template element
which is one of those specifications so
this one's pretty simple it just you
know has a style sheet in it that colors
all inputs read within my shadow DOM and
so its shadow Dom that's polymer is
going to create out this so we're not
going to bleed styles out it's not gonna
color all inputs orange this is all you
have to do and then as soon as the
browser and polymer processes this
people at the bottom here users of your
element can declare it on their page
just as a normal Dom element they can
use Dom to create it using create
element or they can use the new operator
as well but at some point you're
probably going to want to define an API
so just as in the case of select right
had properties and methods it had events
that it fires we'll take our example
that we had before which is that silly
input and we'll just kill this no script
attribute that i have on top here so
when we kill that we can inline a little
script tag that calls the polymer
constructor and pass it the name of the
tag that we're going to create so right
now it's not doing much but we're going
to add to this
the second parameter a second argument
to polymer constructor is a set of
properties and methods that your element
defines so if i use the console for
instance the dev tools and query this
element in the Dom you would get a
length property and you get a ready
method this is a cool little polymer
feature I'm just basically grabbing my
internal input from this tag using the
this dot dollar sign dot and then
referencing the ID of that element such
kind of a convenience thing to get at
the internals of your the guts of your
element and that's all it takes we're
just defining these properties and
methods and they get added to the
prototype of your element I really want
to remind folks that web components
don't change the way you your workflow
for developing web apps so if you want
to do things like reference an external
style sheet you can totally do that if
you want a reference script you can
totally do that you want to use
coffeescript if you want to use sass all
is fair game in this world of web
components ultimately what changes is
your cuz your concept of actually
building apps your composing web
applications based on smaller chunks
that are all compartmentalized this is
also great by the way for CSP give a
shot to Chrome apps which is a strong
CSP environment so you can absolutely
use polymer in those environments as
well one the core features of polymers
be able to publish properties and do
data binding week and this is super
super powerful so we had the example of
the my input before we had just this
input tag that's now I've in line that
style to color it orange and I have two
properties on this this element I have a
type property which is defaulted to text
and I have an orange property which is
defaulted so using a color property
which is defaulted to orange instead I
can kill this sort of redundancy here
and replace that hard code those hard
coded value is with those properties
using data binding and using the
mustache and so now whenever one of
those changes it's two-way data bound
and I can go crazy with this right I can
set up a bunch of markup internal to my
application and tie them together using
data binding so this is pretty cool this
is using polymer local storage so now
every time someone types in this input
right this value is going to change and
its data bound to this polymer local
storage value and I'm automatically
going to persist data using just data
binding and internal to my component
it's very very handy stuff the other
thing if you remember from the Select
case is that
people could you know change the
behavior of the element using attributes
and so in order to do that in polymer we
have this attributes attribute where you
say I want to publish the type property
and I want to publish the color property
and so then what people can do from the
outside world when they use your element
is for instance change the default of
that color property using an attribute
on the tag so they're overriding my
default of orange here to read and so
that's how you are able to customize
elements by publishing these properties
another example of using a stuff in
action is to do something like
responsive design by default I can
create a responsive layout element that
basically handles all the intricacies of
dealing with responsive design so in
this example I'm using polymer media
query element that we've created and
basically using data binding to watch
for changes on the media query so when
this meet this query that I've the past
has been set this query matches is going
to is going to be true so I'm data
binding to that and then I can stamp out
a section of declarative markup using
the template tag so if his phone is true
and that responsive attribute is set I
can show this section of markup in my
element otherwise if it's false I'm
going to show this section of markup so
now we're sort of using dynamic markup
we're using data binding reasoning
reusable elements and it's all sort of
just working internal to my web
component and people from the outside
all they have to do is just declare this
sucker on their page responsive layout
knows what to do with your content it
does the right thing based on the media
queries in it so it's super super handy
so polymer is many things right it's a
set of polyfills to enable this stuff
today again it's landing native browsers
near you as we speak on top of that we
have the core we have the sugaring layer
with has data binding and all that
declarative stuff so you don't have to
sort of reinvent the wheel and do all
this customization over and over again
when you're building a web component and
on top of that we have the set of UI
elements that we want to use and have
you guys just drop those on your page
and everything just works using web
components the part at the top a little
blue part is where you guys come in and
build applications based on web
components you can use any part of the
stack you want if you just want to use
the core
foundational native API is the browser
you can use the polyfills you can use
our sugaring layer to make things more
convenient you can use just the elements
if you don't want to write any code and
just drop things on your page that's
totally totally fine so that's polymer I
encourage you to check out our website
at polymer project org to learn more
there's a lot going on there's a lot of
conceptual things that are changing sort
of how we build web apps as i was
actually researching this this topic in
preparing for the stack I looked up
Wikipedia and actually look through the
definition of polymer and polymer is a
large molecule composed of many repeated
subunits known as monomers I don't know
if you guys knew that but I read this
and I was like whoa if we replace a
couple of words here I actually read
this as a web app is a large collection
of web components composed of many sub
elements known as custom elements a web
app is a large collection of web
components composes many sub elements so
you're building components out of
components out of component set of
components and those are known as custom
elements so I think that's really cool i
think when we start to compartmentalize
things on the web and we can reuse them
we can share them i think that becomes
very powerful it feels super good so i
hope you guys agree to check out polymer
thank you for your time this deck will
be up at that URL again feel free to
follow me on the social channels thanks